okay so the topic of today's video is
going to be cellular respiration an
overview of the process let's go ahead
and get started
so when we look at cellular respiration
first of all what is it it's the process
of our cells producing ATP energy this
molecule right here represents a drawing
of ATP adenosine triphosphate
now cellular respiration is what is
known as an exothermic or an exorganic
reaction because it releases energy
energy in the form of ATP now if we look
at photosynthesis versus cellular
respiration for the chemical equations
photosynthesis molecules of water and
molecules of carbon dioxide
and energy from the Sun
will yield will create will produce a
molecule of glucose and molecules of
oxygen so on the left of the arrow you
should know that these are the reactants
of a chemical equation and on the right
of an arrow these are the products of a
chemical equation well now let's look at
cellular respiration let's look at the
reactants first a molecule of glucose
and six molecules of oxygen
will yield
let's look at the products
six molecules of water six molecules of
carbon dioxide and energy what I'm
hoping you're noticing is that these
chemical reactions are mirrors of one
another the reactants of one of the
products of the other and the products
of one other reactants of the other and
so after photosynthesis glucose is
created and it is used and broken down
during cellular respiration to make ATP
same with the oxygen it's used in
cellular respiration to break down the
glucose and to make ATP
now if you look at the uh the products
of cellular respiration the water and
the carbon dioxide can be used during
the process of photosynthesis so these
two reactions are very much
complementary and in connection and in a
cycle of nature with one another
now when we talk about the energy of
photosynthesis the energy is different
the energy of photosynthesis is sunlight
and in cellular respiration the energy
that is created are molecules of ATP so
the energies are different but the other
molecules are are are the same
well who performs cellular respiration
all eukaryotic organisms are able to
perform cellular respiration so that
would be members of Kingdom Protista
like this amoeba members of kingdom
fungi like the the mushrooms here
members of Kingdom plantae like the
trees and members of Kingdom animalie
like this frog here
where does cellular respiration occur
mostly within this organelle right here
the mitochondria I say mostly because an
early process happens in the cytoplasm
so what happens during cellular
respiration well you have to eat some
food and then the food molecules such as
glucose are going to be used to create
ATP let's zoom on into the bloodstream
of this young lady and there's a couple
cells right there and after a meal you
have a high concentration of glucose in
the bloodstream and so glucose will
diffuse into the cells and in the top
cell the glucose is going into the
mitochondria and the mitochondria is
making and releasing a bunch of ATP now
that happens in the bottom cell also a
glucose enters the mitochondria and a
bunch of ATP are created the ATP will
allow these cells to do the work that
they need to survive
and one molecule of glucose through the
process of cellular respiration can
actually yield about 36 molecules of ATP
when it comes to lipids and
triglycerides that number is even
greater one triglyceride can yield 146
atps well let's actually get into the uh
the process now
okay when we move on to Step One of
cellular respiration and glycolysis when
you look at this picture right here this
is not an over overview this is the full
process of glycolysis it's incredibly
complex follow the the Red Square here
glucose gets broken down and converted
into this which becomes this which
becomes this which becomes this which
becomes this and becomes this and
becomes this and becomes this and
becomes this and eventually you get two
molecules of pyruvate we're not going
into this detail right now we're going
to start with glucose we're going to
break glucose down into a mile into
molecules called pyruvate and I'm going
to highlight a couple things in between
that's the overview we're going to
discuss
so let's look at an overview of
glycolysis the breakdown of glucose so
where does this take place in the
cytoplasm of a cell so in my animation
here comes a g and it's just diffused
into the cytoplasm let's zoom on in a
little bit and there's the glucose
molecule now glucose is not just six
carbons I'm just using this picture
right here to illustrate glucose it also
has 12 hydrogens and six oxygens
and so what happens during glycolysis I
like to use scissors to represent the
actions of enzymes there's a variety of
enzymes that are that are going to break
that glucose molecule down
and when they do they break that
molecule of glucose into two molecules
labeled pyruvate
C3 h4o3 and then two molecules of ATP so
that's an overview of glycolysis from
beginning to end
now what happens next well that's going
to depend if there's oxygen present the
pyruvates in my animation are going to
go into the mitochondria
and that's where aerobic respiration is
going to occur with the help of oxygen
the Krebs cycle and the electron
transport chain will occur
well what if there's not oxygen present
if there's not oxygen present the
pyruvates stay in the cytoplasm and are
further broken down during fermentation
now we are going to follow the aerobic
pathway this video is not going to
discuss fermentation we are going to
discuss from glycolysis to the Krebs
cycle to the electron transport chain so
let's move on next to the Krebs cycle
and when you look at this picture right
here the Krebs cycle is incredibly
complex this diagram here is the full
Krebs cycle we're not going into this
detail notice what it starts with in the
red box a molecule of pyruvate which
becomes this which becomes this which
becomes this which becomes this and then
this and then this and then this and
then this and this and this and this and
back to this the Krebs cycle is
incredibly complex in our overview we're
going to talk about how pyruvate gets
broken down and a few of these items are
created
so in the Krebs cycle which takes place
in the liquidy interior the
mitochondrial matrix it's known as
so what happens during the Krebs cycle
well let's focus on the pyruvate to the
left those pyruvates are there because
of glycolysis and so let's focus on the
pyruvate to the left through a very
complex reaction enzymes are going to
break that pyruvate down I'm going to
highlight a few things that are created
three molecules of carbon dioxide per
pyruvate so one two three molecules of
Pi of carbon dioxide they diffuse into
the bloodstream the heart pumps them to
our lungs and we exhale it I think it's
interesting to know where does our
exhaled breath comes from it comes from
the Krebs cycle
also a single molecule of ATP is created
but more importantly more important than
ATP more importantly molecules called
nadh and fadh2 are created now the
reason these molecules are so important
is that these are hydrogen carriers
they're carrying hydrogen and those
hydrogens are going to be crucial and
the third step coming up which we'll
talk about in a few moments well let's
repeat that process there's another
pyruvate on the right hand side
in total we get two atps because we have
to add the pyruvate on the right hand
side the Krebs cycle happens to this
pyruvate as well
three molecules of carbon dioxide are
created in the breakdown of that
pyruvate they're released as waste
another molecule of ATP is created that
adds to the one from before to make two
total and more nadh and fadh2 are
created let's go on to the third step
next
so let's briefly look at the third step
the electron transport stage when you
see a picture like this again this is
the full detail of the electron
transport chain it's a very complex
chemical reaction we're not going into
this level of detail we're going to
highlight just a few events that happen
in the electron transport chain and it
still even though this is an overview
it's still a tricky overview
so in the overview of electron transport
well where does this occur
see the oranger orange area labeled the
inner membrane space that's where the
majority of this occurs and the inner
membrane space and what's going to
actually happen
nadh and fadh2 they're carrying the
hydrogens and those hydrogens have an
electron
the electrons are pulled into the black
the blackly drawn membrane that you see
in the animation now in that membrane
there are protein pumps I didn't draw
them they're not pictured but they're
there and those protein pumps are
powered by those electrons and so there
are protein pumps that will pump the
hydrogens from The Matrix into the inner
membrane space that frees up the NAD and
fad that frees up the nads and fads to
return to the Krebs cycle to get more
hydrogens but let's focus on the
hydrogens that are currently here what
happens now we've created a
concentration gradient
so there's a concentration gradient
there's a high concentration of gradient
in that orange area there I've just
added what's called ATP synthase ATP
synthase is an enzyme that's really
important what it's going to do is it's
going to bond ADP and a single P to make
ATP and so as hydrogen begins to diffuse
from a high concentration to a low
concentration the energy from those
hydrogens bonds ADP with P to make a
whole bunch of ATP this process happens
repeatedly over and over and over as
long as there's a high concentration
gradient
now that was a key what I just said as
long as there's a high concentration
gradient this process will continue
but as more and more hydrogen diffuses
into the Matrix we're eventually going
to reach equilibrium
equilibrium will basically shut this
process down so something has to come
and remove those diffusing hydrogens
Along Comes the air that we breathe
water waste will be created Here Comes
an O for from the oxygen that we breathe
the oxygen that we breathe will bond
with a couple hydrogens to make water
waste and by taking the water away
notice it maintains the high
concentration gradient in the inner
membrane space so this process can
continue so that would be an overview of
the electron transport stage
so here's a little review for you and
you know these questions right here if
you pause the video if you have to go
back in the video and and find some of
these answers but I want you to find
them on your own I'm not going to
display the answers you got to put the
work in
all right so here's another little
practice quiz for you if you're in my
class you know write these answers on a
separate sheet of paper I'm happy to
check your answers before class or after
class one day thanks for watching